salut vraiment mon pantalon pour ma mère
je pense qu'elle doit être dedans je
vous dise à lui pas du tout pas
seulement pour mettre un peu de
proximité d'intimité plutôt bonsoir je
vous dis salut parce que je voudrais
effectivement et dans l'intimité quand
même un peu dans la confidence en fait
ce que je vais vous faire une confidence
alors c'est une confidence qui peut
paraître comme simple anecdotique on
s'en fiche mais il me semblait
importante de vous la dire cette
confidence c'est que j'adore mon troll
je sais pas si vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un en fait vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un trône parce qu'on a tous un troll
dans la vie un troll
il ya des gens qui ont plus de troll que
d'autres mais tout le monde a un troll
si vous cherchez bien sûr internet
évidemment le troll vous savez c'est
cette étrange créature qui surgit des
tréfonds d'internet et qui est là en
fait souvent sous pseudonyme pour vous
pourrir pour vous éclater pour vous dire
que vous êtes extrêmement mauvais
méchant bête épouvantable le troll il a
envie de vous tuer mais moi j'adore mon
troll je sais comme ça j'adore mon troll
et je voulais vous dire je vais vous
dire pourquoi évidemment déjà je vous
dire que je l'appelle mon troll je sais
pas si c'est un homme ou une femme parce
que le troll en fait c'est toujours au
masculin il vous avisez pas de dire ma
trolls et or là c'est une catastrophe
mais c'est les prendre très cher sur
internet ça m'est arrivé j'en ai souvent
fait les frais donc j'appelle mon troll
effectivement mon troll moi je pense que
c'est une femme
ce troll je vous dis ça parce que bon
déjà je vais pas vous dire exactement la
relation que j'ai avec ce troll parce
que c'est une relation qui est quand
même un team
même si c'est une relation publique mais
je pense que c'est une femme parce que
il surgit ce troll à chaque fois que
j'interviewe une artiste femme c'est
quand même mon métier
allait il est là et elle a tout le temps
de donner des exemples petit flashback
il ya pas si longtemps avril je crois
augustin trapenard vous soutenez donc le
viol donc la vie était 9h40 je sortais
de mon émission
j'allume internet j'allume twitter
augustin trapenard vous soutenez donc le
viol vous conviendrez qu'il yad'autres
matinée
plus agréable et en fait je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi tout ça parce que
j'ai vérifié tout simplement j'avais
invité ce jour là ce matin là le
cinéaste roman polanski dans une
émission culturelle il me paraissait
intéressant d'entendre ce cinéaste
niasse de chinatown de lune de fiel
signal s'il ya un passé que vous
connaissez mais bon je trouvais déjà
peut-être pas dû inviter en fait cela
dit j'ai une vieille histoire avec avec
montreux puisqu'un an et demi plus tôt
mais il était déjà là il était déjà là
voilà donc pareil 9h40 je sors de la
radio j'allume mon ordinateur j'ai sur
internet sur twitter présentement en
train de souffrir
la beaufitude d'augustin traquenard
juste pour entendre le sourire dans la
voix de jessica chastain ofit ud alors
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'en
fait j'avais eu le malheur de mentionner
la couleur de cheveux de mon invitée de
ce jour là qui est donc l'actrice
américaine jessica chastain qui rousse
je le disais à la radio comme on la voit
pas c'est bien quand même de rappeler
aux gens qui sait je me disais c'est
vrai qu'elle est au rose web j'ai
regretté j'aurais pas dû le faire je les
fais plus récemment septembre en
septembre
on travaillait était toujours là dit
augustin trapenard possible de parler
d'autre chose que du petit minois
quand vous parlez d'audrey tautou une
femme avec un f majuscule
alors effectivement je décris mon invité
tous les matins ce que c'est de la radio
soit pas filmé donc eh ben j'ai eu le
malheur d'employer ce terme de petit
minois j'aurais peut-être pas dû
employer ce terme d'ailleurs j'ai
regretté immédiatement à l'excessive
enfin il est excessif mon troll très
excessifs de ces jeux là d'or en fait je
sais pas quoi vous dire j'adore ce troll
parce qu'en fait il a raison il a raison
c'est absurde de parler de la mignonne
rite audrey tautou à la radio pendant
une interview et je vais acte de
contrition c'est pas intéressant tu as
nécessaire de mentionner que jessica
chastain et roux sous peu on le sait ou
alors en bronze pas nécessaire de le
dire quand un roman polanski aussi bon
soit-il immense cinéaste
il ya des gens des auditeurs et des
auditrices des hommes et des femmes
rêvent d'entendre son nom règne de
l'entendre parler ça les hearts ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut que je respecte
donc ça me pose question n'est ce pas
pour ça qu'il a raison mon troll il a
raison justement parce qu'ils me posent
question ils me posent des questions ils
me forcent en fait à m'interroger tout
le temps quelle question est ce qu'il me
pose ou et le sexisme dans mon métier
quelle place est ce que je donne aux
femmes dans mon émission
ce soit à la radio ou à la télévision
comment est-ce que je parle des femmes
comment est-ce que je parle aux femmes
quand je suis un homme est ce que c'est
possible quand on est un homme
d'interroger une femme et vous avez bien
dû se dire interrogé jeudi par cuisine
et sinon mon troll revient d'interroger
une femme sans paraître macho alors moi
je vais vous dire c'est facile tous les
matins en fait chez une programmation
certes je travaille à l'invitation de
cinq invités par semaine or c'est très
compliqué parce qu'il faut varier les
arts
je peux pas avoir un comédien le lundi
un comédien de mardi il faut varier les
arts donc il faut pallier les genres il
faut varier les tonalités il faut varier
va plein de choses en fait il faut un
petit peu de diversité il faut
évidemment de la parité de la mise
cité de l'égalité inutile de vous dire
que c'est un cauchemar cette
programmation c'est un puzzle tous les
jours j'essaie je travaille je me bats
pour faire une bonne une bonne
programmation est évidemment j'espère si
vous avez remarqué mais le plus
compliqué en fait c'est l'égalité à la
radio comme à la télé on entend toujours
plus d'hommes que de femmes peut
paraître être un cliché mais c'est vrai
c'est d'autant plus vrai et intéressant
à mon avis dans le domaine de la culture
où il ya énormément de lectrices vous le
savez d'auditrice il ya vraiment deux
spectatrices bien plus ça m'aurait dit
que de lecteurs auditeurs spectateurs
il ya énormément de femmes artistes
aussi sans doute plus que d'hommes
artiste met à niveau de célébrité égal
on invite toujours d'abord un homme
plutôt qu'une femme alors il faut
résister et même moi qui résistent sans
cesse parce que j'en fais un combat je
vous racontais après mais je me fais
prendre au piège
je me souviens il n'y a pas si longtemps
cette rentrée je construis ma
programmation et j'ai une semaine qui
est exclusivement féminine c'est à dire
que le lundi je crois que j'ai l'actrice
virginie efira le mardi une romancière
céline minard le mercredi sophie marceau
j'étais très content le jeudi brigitte
fontaine j'étais très content aussi
après l'émission un peu moins le
vendredi ouais c'était particulier à la
question qu'est ce qu'une féministe
justement il m'a répondu
quelqu'un qui n'est pas québécoise j'ai
pas compris brigitte fontaine même temps
et le vendredi
j'avais cet immense intellectuel
américaine qui s'appelle series de
atteint et c'est ce que j'ai fait je me
suis vanter de cette programmation c'est
là que j'ai dit c'est génial d'une
semaine exclusivement féminine c'est un
scandale
j'aurais jamais dû me vanter d'une
programmation ça devrait être normal
donc déjà c'était une première erreur
mais la deuxième erreur qui à mon avis
est encore plus grave c'est qu'à
l'antenne j'ai dit une connerie
monumentale
j'ai dis parce que je me disais cereus
bête elle est quand même pas très connue
alors qu'en fait elle est très connue
dans le monde entier mais je le disais
en france a les moins connus que les
autres ont essayé de rattraper le coup
et je vais tissu très léger dit je suis
très content de recevoir cyrus va être
parce que je les ai invités plutôt que
son mari paul auster très maladroit
devrait pas faire ça du tout j'aurais
pas dû
le faire je vais acte de contrition là
encore la moindre des choses quand on
veut une une programmation de mixité
c'est justement ça c'est justement ne
pas s'en vanter
c'est pas insisté mais ça c'est rien la
programmation
parce que très souvent mon troll il me
dit mais le problème c'est pas le sujet
le problème c'est pas les gens que vous
invitez le premier savez pas si vous
parler de féminisme ou pas le problème
c'est les mots que vous employez et
c'est vrai que ce langage que vous
connaissez tous qu'on emploie tous c'est
un langage très souvent très masculin
s'engage machiste un langage qui a en
lui la mémoire du patriarcat
c'est impressionnant alors c'est ça ça
peut être une question savez quelquefois
une question qu'on pose quand on la pose
à une femme soudain ça devient
extrêmement dur on lui demande de se
justifier quelque part ça peut être un
cliché sur la beauté ça peut être un mot
qu'on emploie et du coup c'est toute une
ligne éditoriale qui changent moi je me
souviens récemment j'ai reçu marion
cotillard avoue sa veste il ya trois
semaines c'était tout moment valait pas
en parler ou en plein divorce de brad
pitt et angelina jolie
un site américain nous a expliqué que
marion cotillard était sans doute
responsable alors tout me disait alors
tu vas lui poser la question et là j'ai
pas posé la question
alors d'abord parce que ça m'intéresse
pas mais ça la limite où pouvez-vous
dire ça ne m'intéresse pas il ya des
auditeurs qu'ils écoutent ce que les
intéressés
donc il pourrait poser la question c'est
une première chose en suisse que je suis
dit ça va la heurter vous avez enfin les
bien gentil on n'est pas là pour lui
servir la soupe si ça nous intéresse est
quand même répondre à une question ça va
mais c'est pas pour ça en fait j'ai pas
posé cette question parce que six jeunes
avaient posé un homme ça aurait été
drôle et quand la pause à une femme
c'est pas drôle c'est insultant parce
que cette question elle porte en elle la
mémoire d'une soumission
elle porte en elle elle charrie elle
véhicule des clichés épouvantables
contre lesquels il s'agit sans cesse de
lutter et c'est la moindre des choses
quand on fait mon métier
moi je suis féministe alors
je le dis je discutais ministre je suis
féministe je dis aux hommes à mes frères
je le dis aux machos à mes frères je dis
aux femmes
je le dis aussi aux féministes pas
forcément ce qui est plus facile parce
que vous le savez il ya certaines
féministes qui me regardent et qui me
disent ne fait pas les ministres au
mieux tu es un allié du féminisme
étaient pas un délit mais t'es pas
féministe parce que le féminisme c'est
par et pour les femmes d'âgés vous dire
en plus d'une programmation que je
voudrais plus mixte en plus d'un langage
auquel je veille pour ne pas qu'il
heurte j'ai un troisième défi c'est
celui d'être féministe et de le dire
haut et fort et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis signataire
je suis signataire et ambassadeur de la
campagne i fochi dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure que vous connaissez parce
qu'elle a été fondée par l'onu femmes et
parce qu'elle est portée par cette
formidable comédienne anglaise qui emma
watson qui est une campagne qui lutte
contre les stéréotypes mais surtout qui
engage les hommes et les garçons à
lutter contre ces stéréotypes et c'est
une campagne que j'aime que je signe que
je resigne ray parce qu elle nous engage
parce qu'elle nous invite à partager
parce qu'elle est à mon sens centrale et
je vous invite du coup à devenir
signataires de qui font chier parce que
vous êtes si vous êtes des hommes et des
garçons possiblement féministe et vous
avez droit de le dire je suis féministe
et là je suis très étonné que mon troll
ne soit pas réapparu ce que quand on dit
je suis féministe heures la gare et à
papa tient le voilà il réapparaît
médiane il déteste qu'on dit ce qu'on
n'existe plus le voir ce troll en fait
je les adore mais je peux plus me voir
parce que en fait que j'aimerais c'est
qu'ils se taisent
une fois qu'ils disparaissent qu'ils
soient plus là qui sont taillé une fois
ou alors qu'il me fasse un compliment
pas pour me dire qu'il est convaincu que
féministe parce que je le sais j'ai pas
besoin de lui
mais pour ce qu'ils se disent qu'à une
infime possibilité pour que la question
ne se pose plus
[Applaudissements]